the kia defensive player of the year
there he is rudy gobert we uh
we joined your teammates in applauding
this a third time
in the last four years for you uh and
they got
quite the setup there for you rudy
they've they've done this
up big time there in salt lake city wow
how about that
that's kind of cool there very little
set almost yeah very nice
so so uh let me let me ask the first
question and
in part part of it's really a statement
it just seems appropriate rudy
that you are given this award for the
third time
um less than 24 hours after a huge
defensive play that sealed the win
against
the clippers take me through it
i mean we we're up three you know so we
we know that they're looking for for a
three-point shot obviously
joe and roy did an amazing job uh
switching on the dho and uh
and joe was just uh you know amazing
taking away the three for kawaii and uh
you know it just swung the ball through
maurice and was open so i had to
try to give the best contest that i
could julia congratulations on another
fabulous year
three times defensive player over here
what type of mentality does it take to
say you know
i want to be the defensive player of the
year obviously charles couldn't play
defense i couldn't play defense
but for you to win it three times in a
row what type of mentality
does it take to say you know what i'm
gonna just be a defensive player of the
year
i think it takes team effort you know it
takes uh
obviously toughness mental toughness and
uh you know it's uh
just hard work dedication you know it's
every single day you gotta come in with
a mindset to
you know try to try to make your team as
good as it can be on that end
and you know i have an organization a
coaching staff my teammates that all
believe in me every single night
and uh you know and and i give them that
confidence back and we do it together
and
you know we'll be able to to do it for
many many years so it's a
it's a it's a blessing rudy number one
uh congratulations thank you secondly
utah jazz
number one seed in the western comfort
the favorite
how are you wearing that title
i mean we we don't feel like we
accomplished much yet
you know we obviously it's been a great
year we've never finished first in the
nba since i've been here so it's uh
you know it's been an amazing season but
we know that uh you know we
we have a higher goal and it's to win a
championship and
you know we want to keep you know keep
playing the way we know we can play
during the playoffs and uh you know and
hopefully we get an opportunity to to to
play for that because that's the
that's the best of the accomplishment
that we can get as a team
rudy you know i have a two-part question
the first is you know
they always say that it takes a lot of
effort obviously to play defense
would you say it's uh more effort or
more strategy
in terms of knowing what to do on the
defensive end that's the first part and
i'll let you
and then i'll ask a second i mean it's
both
you know you you know you guys know
you've been in this lake for a while
it's you know uh there's so much talent
you know every single night
someone is trying to come at you and
change whether you're a good team or bad
team teams are trying to come at you and
and you know and score and you know it's
uh we we play in the league that's today
it's really
oriented on the offensive side of the
board and
you know it's uh we got so much talent
that you know for me
it's every single day i know that you
know it's going to be a
it's going to be a battle and a
challenge so it's i've kind of
embraced that over the years and uh and
like i said you know we
having coach quinn snyder behind me and
and all the guys
you know that pushed me every single day
it's been a it's been just uh
it's been exciting and it's been amazing
you know and uh i don't take none of
that for granted
hey really my second part i played with
a guy in high school who was a great
defensive player in the aau whatever
didn't that thing and he and the one day
he said to me he said
i was like man how you play such great d
but well he said you know what though
i'd rather get
40 than play d kenny so i'ma ask you
this question
if you had the chance to get 50 in a
game
or 15 blocks in a game which would you
take
as the defensive player of the year i
mean
i'll take the win you know but uh i
think 15 blocks
i don't know if anyone done that before
you know but 50 points is pretty cool
too so
whatever has my uh whenever has my team
you know at the end of the day
everything i do is
to try to help my team win and you know
and uh whether i have to set screens or
roll to basket
play defense i'm trying to do everything
i can to to win and
that's the bottom line rudy last thing
from this end and this is just something
i
i find interesting with all the award
winners that we talk to
is that when you consider this award now
it's three times
um where does your mind go who do you
think about
who made this possible who had the
biggest impact on you who instilled
confidence and ability and will and that
kind of thing
oh my mom you know she she sacrificed a
lot for me to be able to to do what i
love
she believed in me as a kid and and you
know and uh
she allowed me to you know
do what i love to do and do what i
wanted to do and
you know i wasn't you know i grew up in
a small town in france i wasn't really
supposed to
to be here and if you would ask me when
i was you know when i started basketball
if you would ask me
if i was going to win a defensive player
of the year i would have probably
not believed it but three of them
you know it's just uh just amazing and
you know and it's all her you know she
she gave me everything she she taught me
how to be a
good person and you know and i wouldn't
be there without her
wow rudy gobert congratulations man and
uh
we're happy for you and uh trey bien uh
we uh we wish you the best too uh
down the road in the nba playoffs rudy
gobert three-time defensive player of
the year
well deserved you know we're born